think that there's nobody involved with
wendy williams show that was happy about
the way it ended right
[Applause]
this was a show that had been on the air
for 13 years there was a love for
wendy herself and so it was distressing
um
to see her not being a condition to be
there you know i think a lot of people
involved with the show didn't hear from
her for several months um you know a
good portion of the season which again
was distressing um and i think that
there was a sort of a general feeling of
a really sort of this bitter sweetness
to the end of the show the concerns
about her health uh are vast there was a
zoom call at the beginning of the season
it was you know 10 days or so after the
season was supposed to launch it had
already been pushed back by a couple of
weeks there were you know headlines
galore about different sort of health
struggles that wendy was going through
so the heads of the production company
put together a
zoom call with wendy to basically say
have a look at her
talk to her uh
reassure them things were going to be
okay
uh and so that's what they did
unfortunately it did not go as planned
and the many people i spoke to sort of
described a scenario where
she was sort of rambling she sort of
became incoherent she was talking about
oh i'm fine i'm gonna be fine it's all
gonna be fine but it was very clear to
everybody watching that she wasn't fine
and that she wasn't going to sort of be
back at the show anytime soon so it it
did exactly the opposite of what it was
supposed to do which was calm the fears
of the staff i mean the producers
involved at the wendy williams show they
waited as long as they possibly could
and then arguably even longer for wendy
to come back she was someone who had
performed incredibly well she had a
fiercely loyal fan base they wanted her
to come back they pushed the stations as
as long as they possibly could before
deciding
you know we've got to make a call here
and we can't renew the maybe wendy
williams show and in at that time they
decided to replace her with a show with
with sherry shepherd what they said to
her each time they spoke to her from you
know february all the way up until quite
frankly quite frankly very recently is
we'd love to work with you again we'd
love to have you back on the air but we
need to know that you are actually okay
to be back on the air and the way to do
that is to provide a doctor's
note it is something that insurance
companies would need to be able to uh
you know support uh such a
thing to be able to to be able to
ensure someone uh in her position uh
could come back on the air this is a
woman who hasn't who's been off the air
for an entire year they needed to know
she was okay they needed a doctor's
diagnosis and a note to say she was
capable of performing
on a daily basis
and that was something according to all
of my sources that she was unable or
unwilling to provide there were a number
of phone conversations between wendy and
the producers this past april where each
time wendy didn't realize that her show
was ending she was you know she's sort
of confused about well wait a second
what's what's sherry shepard doing and
is is my is my i'm coming back right and
so each time these producers had to have
these heartbreaking conversations with
her and tell her again and again that in
fact uh the show isn't coming back they
hadn't heard from her for you know eight
nine months uh she wasn't in a position
to be back on air as far as as they
could tell i think that there was like a
lot of a lot of sort of debate and
discussion around how to actually end
the show
and you know people had a lot of
opinions about it but internally there
were also a lot of opinions and a lot of
back and forth about how do you how do
you say goodbye to a show without its
hosts um and she's very much alive um
and
and everything was considered the only
thing that was not considered was
bringing wendy back
so i don't know if that's something
that's relevant or interesting
you